so it takes 2 700 people to put on the  oscars and every job is equally  important okay the gaffers the camera  people  the seat fillers everybody all right and  so what the seat fillers do i hear you  see fillers um i'll just explain what  you do  uh so when you get up to go to the  bathroom or if you're going to cry  because you didn't win um  some oh my god uh actually you know what  let me just show you what the seat  fillers do okay here's the seat filler  can we get you up honey you want to go  to the bathroom okay what let's just get  you thank you seafillers love them jesse  i love doing power of the dog  you know that was my wife  you're married to that seat filler  oh that's weird  you